i've heard some people attempt to argue
that balrogs could have
vestigial wings this i find a very
comical
uh suggestion in the end as why would an
immortal being
who would manifest themselves in a body
have a vestigial anything
right like would seriously would balrogs
be like what i really need for my form
is
decorative non-functional wings that
just doesn't really make any sense to me
hi this is corey olson the tolkien
professor and this is part two
of tolkien support
[Music]
loren asks do orcs just think all elven
weapons glow blue
only the really scary ones it's not just
an
automatic property of elvish weapons but
one of the things that we see in tolkien
is that great craftsmen great and
powerful craftsmen
are able to invest the things that we
make with
some thing of their own spirit something
of their own desires to infuse some of
their own
spirit or will into what they do now
obviously the biggest example of this is
sauron
and the ring but i don't even mean on
that kind of level the elves and their
passionate
cold hatred of the orcs and their
opposition against everything the orcs
stand for
is what is infused into those old swords
from gondolin the old smiths from
gondolin
filled their weapons uh with their own
anger against the goblins and that's why
those swords glow blue it's an
expression
of that spirit so it's not an automatic
thing so the orcs won't think that all
elf weapons glow blue
but they know what it means they are
very aware
they can feel the anger of the ancient
elves the potent anger of the
ancient elves when they see those blue
weapons that's why they freaked them out
so much
dan roberts asks the classic question if
gandalf can summon eagles why didn't
frodo just hop a ride to mount doom and
drop the ring into the fire
answer because that would be an
incredibly
boring story i would add gandalf can't
summon eagles he doesn't have an eagle
summoning ring or an eagle summoning
moth
eagles are free agents and indeed there
are some implications in the text
that they are free agents who operate
under the command
of the lords of the west of the valar
themselves so
no they don't intervene in the world at
all times and under
they are not a ferry service they are
not a taxi service
it's almost just like saying why doesn't
god just reach down and smite all the
bad guys right away
well sure he could do that but there are
reasons that he doesn't and those same
reasons apply
to why the eagles don't take them into
mordor i would add
as a final note it probably wouldn't
work sauron is an air force too
sauron could see the eagles coming and
he could personally get
to mount doom before the eagles that he
sees coming in from a distance could and
uh
that would probably not go well when
they got there in that case
as there's no open caldera at the top to
drop the ring in from the top so
it wouldn't work but most importantly it
would be a pretty bad story
alexander asks why does the ring not
turn
sauron invisible is that explained
somewhere
the reason it doesn't turn sour and
invisible is that he doesn't have a body
in the normal way when bilbo finds the
ring in the hobbit
and finds that it turns him invisible
that's kind of the way that he
understands it right he
he has this ring and so he's like oh
it's a magic invisibility ring
that's cool and of course when tolkien
wrote the story that's kind of what it
was right when he
decides that the ring of pat that the
ring is a ring of power and in fact it's
it has more and different powers than
merely the turning invisible
he kind of retcons uh the uh the
invisibility thing
and he decides that the invisibility is
actually gonna be
kind of a side effect essentially of the
larger power of the ring
the ring wraiths exist and so there's
this like
there's this there's the physical world
and there's the spiritual world
a spirit in tolkien's world can go
around the world invisibly right they
don't
necessarily interact with the physical
world some spirits can take on a body
sauron is one of these he can give
himself a body and interact
uh with the physical world the
ringwraiths
are men who were drawn into
the wraith world basically they are
remember uh bilbo
is uh says that he feels like butter
scraped over too much bread
right the ring wraiths have been scraped
over so much bread
that there's nothing at all left of them
they're almost completely immaterial
not completely immaterial in the sense
that they can hold
objects right they can interact with the
physical world
but they no longer really have physical
bodies anymore
they dwell it once in the wraith world
in the physical world
and more and more as they are dominated
as they
you know they get drawn into the wraith
world so when you put on the ring
you're not just magically it's not like
you're affecting people's vision or the
way light
reflects off you or something like that
you are actually like
going with your whole self into the
wraith world
it doesn't affect sauron this way
because he doesn't have a body he's not
immortal
the invisibility thing is a consequence
of when mortals have
because mortals are being drawn into
sauron's world but he lives there
right uh and he's chosen from that world
in which he lives
to manifest a body so that manifest body
doesn't become invisible because he
doesn't want it to be
that's the way that tolkien kind of
constructed the whole or reconstructed
the invisibility thing after he decided
that the ring was a ring of power
jenna j asks is the ring like a
sisterhood of the traveling pants
situation does it fit everyone what do
you do if it doesn't fit you
if not are sauron's hands the same size
as gollum and frodo
please help me okay uh the answer is yes
the ring of power is almost exactly like
the traveling pants
there are some differences i admit but
tolkien does explicitly say that the
ring does change
size it change sizes to adjust uh to its
owner
um and this is important this represents
the ring has a kind of bond
you have to claim the ring like you have
to know what you're doing you have to
take the ring
and intend to keep it you don't have to
know that it's a ring of power
before you start but if you claim
ownership of the ring
then it forms a kind of bond with you it
can magically change its size
so that it can fit any hand that takes
it up it is willing to take
any master who claims it but it won't
necessarily stay with him it can reject
its master as it seems to have done with
gollum and as it seems to have done with
a sildore
okay carrie frye asks lord of the rings
question i'm too lazy to research could
sam have carried the ring
yes in fact sam did carry the ring in
both directly and indirectly
when he thought frodo was dead he took
it from frodo's body
thinking that he was gonna have to carry
it into mordor himself
uh he only bore it for a short time uh
before of course he found frodo again
and returned it to frodo so he does
carry it and therefore clearly could
have carried it he also carries it
indirectly in that
in the last stages of the journey of
course he carries frodo who is carrying
the ring on his back so
sam does of course himself convey the
ring you know still
around frodo's neck uh to mount doom
could sam have been the ring bearer
could he have been the one
well i mean no he couldn't without
taking it away from frodo
and that would have destroyed frodo
frodo would clearly have
assaulted him so sam does what he has to
do sam
can't carry the ring but he can carry uh
frodo
uh and the ring with it okay julie
decaro asks
why is the entrance to moria in elvish
isn't the elvish word for friend
mithrandir no it might seem a synonym
the elvish word for friend is in fact
melon the entrance to moria is in elvish
because this was the door that faced
the kingdom of the elves so in the old
days before
moria fell back in the second age of the
world maurya was the greatest of the
kingdoms of the dwarves
their next door neighbors in aragian
right there
kelebrimbor and the elves of aragian
were friends
with the dwarves of moria and they
worked together a lot they traded with
each other a lot
so that gate was built there basically
in order to be
the liaison between the the dwarves of
moria and the elves of oregon
so that's why the inscription is in
elvish and that's why the command word
was in elvish because it was designed to
be the elves
private entrance basically uh into the
kingdom of the dwarves
kind of computer jawa has asked no
living man may hinder
the witch king but does bayern in bear
form
count surely not as he is a bear not a
man
and thus free to maul the boss ring
wraith that is an
interesting exploit uh kind of computer
jawa
i think it wouldn't work because there's
a question of course there's an open
question in the hobbit
about what bjorn is is he a man who can
turn into a bear or is he a bear who can
turn into a man right
ultimately what is he in the text it's
not really clear gandalf gives his
opinion
that bayern is a man who has the power
to turn into a bear and
tolkien seems to basically think that
gandalf is probably right about that
so i don't think that the shape that he
takes
ultimately changes like his identity he
is a man
in bear form he may be a bear but he's
really a man
in bear's shape it's a change of shape
not a change of essence
so i think he would not be able to get
off on that technicality and they
couldn't just call it of course apart
from the fact that bjorn is dead at that
point
but i don't think they could have sent
bjorn to hunt down the witch king
but it's an excellent suggestion haley
parr asks
if the ring is constantly being sought
out by sauron and the eye of mordor
how did it end up in a lake for two
thousand years what river
technically not lake but great question
a lot of people assume
that sauron has a kind of like ring
detector or at least like ring proximity
detector
i think there's plenty of evidence in
the text
that sauron cannot detect the presence
of the ring
from a distance if you look at the maps
of middle earth
the spot where the ring was in the river
for thousands of years more than two
thousand years is actually
pretty close to the place where sauron
set up
his headquarters um doguldur in southern
merkwood
he was quite close to where the ring was
for quite some period of time
if sauron had a ring proximity detector
it would certainly have been going off
at some point and even of course
the evidence of the lord of the rings
itself he can't tell
when it's there in mordor it's just
miles away from him
at that point far closer than it's been
for a really really long time
i think it's pretty clear from the text
that sauron cannot sense
the ring's presence and the ring
approaching tony mcdonough
asks if it hadn't rained at helm's deep
would the battle have gone differently
that's a fascinating
question i think it's probably to the
advantage of the defenders
that it was raining especially since
they would be on firmer ground we know
that there's a river that's emerging
through there
and so the whole area would probably
have become muddy and
a great deal of running water through
there it's actually an element
that peter jackson didn't really include
which i'm not saying it would have
washed them away like the flood of
isengard or the deluge
at the fort of bruinin but it certainly
would have made the movement of armies a
little bit inconvenient so i think if it
inconvenienced anyone
it certainly would have inconvenienced
the orcs more than it inconvenienced the
defenders
so if anything probably the rain was
definitely
a net gain there if it would have gone
differently i think it would have been
harder for the defenders but it is
possible to see
the inclement weather there as being a
kind of
mercy on the part of the defenders okay
matt daniels
asks in the 1937 version of the hobbit
how did bilbo come into possession of
his
ring answer actually in exactly the same
way that's not one of the things that
tolkien changed so
bilbo putting his hand accidentally on
the ring in the dark while he's crawling
around
is how he finds it in the original as
well as later
the changes that tolkien made to the
1937 version
are primarily to the end of the
um the terms of the middle game and the
end of the riddle game and actually
one of the other interesting trends that
you can notice he makes gollum creepier
and a little bit scarier by adding more
sounds like the hissing sibilant sounds
that gollum makes are much more
pronounced in the later version
like he's going out of his way to make
gollum a little creepier
in the second version than he was in the
first but the actual the original story
of the finding
of the ring is the same in the 37
version jeremy simmons
uh asks one of the all-time classic
questions
what is tom bombadil he says it's his
first question for talking in the
afterlife hopefully by then he'll have
an answer
of course jeremy referring to the fact
that uh tolkien
was well not shy on this point but
doesn't answer it straight out
one thing we know for certain is tom
bombadil is not an elf he's not a man
he's not a mortal creature
that's perfectly clear we know this
because in his
speech that he gives to the hobbits when
he talks about how long he's been here
he says he saw the little people
arriving he saw the men come he saw the
elves come through
he's been there since before the elves
awoke in quebec and he predates elves
the existence of elves right
so he's not one of the valar they're in
valinor
they have other jobs tom has established
himself in his little domain
and this is where he lives with his wife
goldberry goldberry is also a spirit
she is a spirit of the river actually so
tom bombadil
is that kind of thing he is a spiritual
being
he's a kind of nature spirit but he's
different he's not like quite like
goldberry
he clearly did descend into arda from
outside he says he was there from the
beginning before melkor arrived in
middle earth i know that there are some
people who really like this sort of
semi-conspiracy theory
that tom bombadil is actually god
himself is actually a louvitar
in physical form that's a charming idea
and there's a lot of things that i love
about that reading
but it's clearly not true the proponents
of this theory
point to goldberry's response when frodo
asks her
who is tom bombadil and she answers he
is and a lot of people are like hey it's
like the name of god in exodus right i
am that i am
tolkien actually explicitly addressed
this like he knew
of this theory and he responded to it
very clearly and he said actually first
of all
there's a big difference between he is
and i am that i am
and he points to the context right
goldberry says he is
and then she pauses and then says he is
as you have seen him what she's talking
about is
labels names what does it mean right as
tom addresses exactly the same thing
himself later when frodo asks him the
question
who are you master and tom bombadil says
eh what
don't you know my name yet and he says
defrodo who are you
alone yourself and nameless right you
are
your name your name is a label like how
do you capture who you are
and what it means to be you so what are
you asking of me exactly
and tom goes on and that's when he gives
that speech i was just talking about
about how long he's been there and how
much he's seen he gives
even a kind of answer to that question
i'm not a hobbit i'm not a human i'm not
an elf
i have been here since essentially the
creation of the world
so draw your own conclusions therefore
frodo about what and who you think i
am but he's definitely not identifying
himself as god that's
pretty clear greg maletik asks
how much time passes between the start
of fellowship
and the end of the return of the king
answers a little more than a year
so when well okay the start of the
fellowship of course is
bilbo's party right and that's 17 years
earlier so you got bilbo's party
and then he goes away and then 17 years
pass
until gandalf shows up to frodo uh for
chapter two
right and has the conversation about the
ring of power so there's a 17 year gap
there in the very beginning
but after that 17-year gap it's in the
late spring
when gandalf shows up to frodo and he
delays for some time he doesn't leave
until bilbo's birthday right is when he
moves out of bag end
and september when he moves when he
leaves the shire but remember when
they're coming home
in the return of the king after the
whole adventure has happened and they're
on the homeward road
he's inside of weathertop when the
one-year anniversary of his being
stabbed at weathertop
comes in so the whole story takes a
little bit less
than a year essentially oh i should say
a little bit more than a year actually
until they get back and then some more
time passes when they get back home
so the last chapter uh has a few years
uh passing before frodo and bilbo
then depart on the ship um but the
primary
action from the shadow of the past when
gandalf comes and has the conversation
with frodo
until the scouring of the shire is maybe
16 17 months something like that and mog
asks dare we do the balrog wings thing
okay yes so do balrogs have wings
this is probably the most classic
internet talking question of all time
and the answer is no balrogs
definitely clearly authoritatively
do not have wings there are no
wings on balrogs this is extremely
clear in the text the balrogs are like
the great bad guys um they are the
primary lieutenants
of melkor they're basically on a par
with sauron essentially sauron is the
brains of the operation
the balrogs are kind of thugs but still
they are the heavy infantry the really
heavy infantry
infantry i stress not air force of
melchor
in the first stage they are always
described as
running and they are on the ground in
fact tolkien makes a big deal about the
fact that melchor does not have an air
force he does not have any
winged support at all until the winged
dragons are revealed at the very end
in every battle that the balrogs are
described as participating
they are running in front of the armies
they are climbing walls they cannot
possibly fly also the fact that more
than one balrog
meets its end by plummeting off a cliff
is also
highly suggestive that the balrogs do
not
in fact have wings there are only two
reasons why anybody
thinks that balrogs might or should have
wings
and the primary one is the description
that tolkien gives of it
at the the bridge of kaza doom he says
that as the balrog steps out
shadow spreads around it like two vast
wings
right so he uses a simile comparing it's
just it's just
darkness the balrog is so powerful it's
so intimidating
that darkness itself spreads around it
and so
in order to try to convey visually what
that looks like he compares the darkness
to like two wings there's one other line
people who are really kind of grasping
at straws to try to prove that balrogs
have wings
will point to a sentence in appendix a
which
says that the balrogs flew
from thangarodrim in the old days that
means ran away very fast like they fled
from thangarodram so and and you'll
notice of course
in the very bridge of kaza doom scene
gandalf
uses the word in exactly that he says
fly you fools
and i don't think that he is under any
illusion that frodo and aragorn and
boromir have wings
he's telling them to run away very fast
and that's what the balrogs did from
thangaroadrim at the end of the first
stage
visual artists universally find
that balrogs look much cooler with wings
and you know what they're totally right
there's no question
that a balrog with like huge demon wings
is
totally scarier looking than a balrog
without
huge demon wings like i get it they look
super cool
with wings but in the text no balrogs do
not have wings
i'm corey olson the tolkien professor
and this has been tolkien support
thanks for your awesome questions i
imagine sort of tolkien's mind back in
the 30s when he was first getting the
hobbit published and what he would have
thought
to imagine us having these kinds of
discussions
by twitter and youtube as we're still
thinking about
and engaging with his world all these
years later uh thanks
for your time and interest in energy and
i hope you learned something about
tolkien today